what's up guys we're on our way to watch
more videos on the screening about 90 minutes
away they're gonna reveal right afterwards so
we're gonna need to keep our energy up energy
we're gonna need to focus on focus because between
driving screening filming and editing it's gonna
be like nine hours in total endurance and we're
gonna wanna make sure to give you the sharpest
reaction right after screening it we react
that's what we do because we want to thank
our video sponsor today g fuel we're gonna
stop with this next ring infused plasma flavor
we're up all hours of the day and night ain't
no rest ain't no breath we're very biased
g-fuel is gluten and sugar-free vitamin
and antioxidant fortified to keep us alert
and focused for these late night filming and
editing runs 40 flavors for taste bud variety
so hit up that link in the description box
and we'll see you after the movie we vape
well we just got out of morbius had a special
screening that apparently coy was hosting
they found me you're going to be in the video
with us now yeah here i am all right guys look
it's no secret if you watch the real rejects john
and i have heard some things about this movie some
some awful things and i'm not gonna lie i'm really
not just saying this i was like it's not that bad
talk about shocks this is not a train wreck i
think people are expecting a different thing
and this is the thing i wanted so i was happy
look look i'm not gonna [ __ ] you guys like i
think that there were times where i was like kind
of checking out a little bit the kind of image
that this movie was getting beforehand is like oh
this is a disaster i'm like no for the most part
yeah it's a little silly it's a little
cheesy sometimes it takes itself a little too
serious where it falls flat instead of feeling
dramatically weighty when the movie thinks it is
is it rushed and choppy at times yeah i mean i
didn't think it was like rushed to the degree i
felt venom let there be carnage was however there
are plenty of scenes where it was very obvious
stuff was cut out so obvious a more breathable
less non-stop info dumb back-to-back scenes
version of this exists could have been rated r to
make the action better a thousand percent could
the movie have overall been more interesting
and better yeah would it have been getting as
much crap if it was just on streaming probably not
but i don't know i i think a lot of this has to do
with my expectations were solo and seeing how sony
handled venom i was like yeah this lines up and
yet for the most part i was still consistently
amused i thought the actors showed up and some
of the action and effects were all right so yeah
it's fine i don't think it's as horrible as people
have been making it out to be matt smith though
matt smith man smith absolutely yeah matt smith
mvp of the movie definitely he was my favorite
part the trailers remarkably didn't show a whole
lot of them there's a lot of the movie that is
not in the trailers and a lot of that is matt
smith and he's in it much more prominent than uh
the trailers let on at all and he has the most
arc he is the most interesting character and he's
having the most fun and he elevates the movie the
most i can't stress that enough matt smith is
like the best part of the film it did feel like
a night i thought you were when you said i was
serious i thought you were just like being kind
no it's a very intentional tone it is good
it's a it's like a 90s vampire movie and i love
that because that's what i wanted it to be
yeah it's kind of like a 90s vampire movie but
a little bit void of the violence so john and
i cracked up at one point in this movie when
someone's throat gets slashed and uh it's
just like they have all the sound effects
yeah he had given blood that day actually
so there wasn't much left to go around
very easy to catch i mean i actually really
liked martine as well i thought she was a great
presence aside from just like the geekiness
of like oh i love matt smith and he's doing a
great job here i thought that she was actually
perhaps the most standout character aside from
him like i thought she brought a good amount of
heart and played off jared leto well i also love
that every supporting cast member had fun like
with their like jared harris is a great time
and tyrese is a great time and al madrigal
getting to just play much like a 90s vampire
movie everyone's just vibing and having a good
time knowing what movie it is i think coy's level
of enthusiasm for this movie koi's having a blast
and john are like yeah it was fun it's all right
had a good time it was a good time it's terrible
i don't necessarily agree that everyone was in
the same movie but i enjoyed watching everyone oh
nikoi i gotta disagree with you okay who was not
i'm gonna do an impression of you for every
tyrese gibson scene all right a scene's happening
i'm out of magical i'm making jokes
tyrese walks in i say one line and you see
but incredibly serious line at that is that not
a 90s vampire movie he's the same movie everyone
else is in he's not he's not a character he's
just you could excise that plot line completely
from the movie and it would not change but you
know what you wouldn't have tyreese i'd be sorry
isn't even charismatic in this movie two things
i liked tyra's not bad for now so uh i'm glad
they kept that plot the tyrese gibson and then
who's the guy who played his partner al madrigal
yeah daily show correspondent genius writer comic
book they did not have chemistry his jokes all
landed flat i don't recall one time people left
no there was one joke actually there was one joke
for sure for sure out of like 50. at a certain
point in time my brain just kind of normalized
it is no this is just how this character speaks
and there's no real humorous or non-humorous
value to that this is how this guy speaks it was
a little bit more violent than i was expecting
at times there were times where i was like oh
you're not quite r-rated but you're you're you're
doing something i also think it got it captured
this really cool like tense claustrophobic tone
that i liked keeping unique to this like it
has that very 90s everything feels very rotten
taught and i really think that's something we
are not getting in the superhero genre as much
yes i thought i didn't ever find it intense
look i don't hate this movie i'm really not just
saying that for me i'm like no it's it's perfectly
enjoyable like that's that's the thing is it's in
it it's so like not offensive and then just like
do you like vampire movies you'll probably like
this one yeah i would happily watch a morbius 2.
but yeah i think like geraldo is actually not bad
in the movie i don't think he's like special per
se my concern was that jared leto would be boring
in this movie i really thought he might be boring
this feels like the most like you're just hanging
out with actual jared leto in a weird way it
felt like we're just hanging out with a guy that
was enjoyable to me it's meant as a compliment
it is like i've been doing press for this full
disclosure i'm at the event that i was hosting i
recently hung out jared leto it is and like it's
interesting you know what i mean and like i like
the vibe they captured of morbius because michael
morbius has the dichotomy the hippocratic oath
and also the thirst and you feel that tension
i think yeah they taught they do the outline man
uh they do execute a plot i think freaking matt
smith scenes are all great some of the action
scenes well while the cgi is kind of back and
forth because i feel like there were times where
the cgi looked like really good where i thought
they were doing practical effects but then when
you see the way they handle some shots you're like
oh there's no way that could be practical effects
that has to be a cgi shot sometimes it looks like
a cut scene in a this is like a zombie arcade game
is how i put it like a modern day zombie arcade
game or some of the fight scenes but sometimes
i'm like it's pretty cool some of you guys have
heard about the post-credits scenes what how on
the internet when the movie just ended i was like
oh it's just it's just over like i thought there
was going to be like 10 to 15 more minutes to
wrap this movie up i thought there was an act
missing but it just like oh it's done and then
they do the post credit scenes and we had heard
some of the stuff about the post credit scenes
i'm not gonna lie to you guys i thought they were
a little worse than what i even heard i was kind
of surprised the movie is so much better than the
post-credits scenes and the post-credits scenes
just raised so many questions for me where i was
like wait a minute what that was just me like the
entire time with the post credits and it's like
what what they are shameless i think there are
solutions i just want to see them i'll happily
watch how those post-credit scenes conclude and
what they blossom into later but as you know
marketing tools as most post-credit scenes
tend to be nowadays they really felt like very
transparent bullet point marketing tools i felt
like there was a whole movie that happened
off screen between post credit scene 1 and
postgres scene 2. this is just one aspect of it
one aspect of it sort of felt like they definitely
cut out some scenes from the actual movie and
then re-shot some scenes too to make the postcards
scene happen and i wonder how much of that had to
do with like the order it come out in because like
this was supposed to come out before no way home
yeah yeah in defense of morbius i keep describing
this is the third movie in the sony universe
of marvel characters i keep describing them
as universal monster movies and i don't mean like
universal studios today i mean classic 40s and 50s
30s 40s and 50s universal monster movies but with
today's technology and those movies are a blast
and they're interesting and what is beautiful
about the sony universe of marvel characters is
this keeps the pace different if everything feels
like one studio makes it then we'll lose the
bubble will burst there's a reason dc diversifying
its content is succeeding there's a reason we need
movies to feel different this and venom feel like
a different thing than the other movies made from
this comic book company and i think that's
its strength they might not be for everyone
but they are for a lot of people i think this is
as long as the press doesn't keep people at home
i think this has the potential to do really really
well and i really want it to because i want more
of this so we don't have the bubble burst we
don't have the same thing you want more orbeez
either one pick your favorite out in
the comments who did the joke better
but i also know that and like it was the joker
last week at moonlight they were like koi likes
everything i just don't talk about things i
don't like there's plenty that if you look in my
letterbox i don't enjoy i'm just like hiding from
it i prefer to hype things i liked this at my age
i liked it but if i was between like 15 and 25 and
hadn't grown up with lost boys or interviewed the
vampire or the movies that shaped my childhood i
feel like matt smith captured that oh dude me and
matt talked about that wow yeah i see the michael
thing i really feel like this should have been
a matt smith's movie and he becomes like at times
he's the only part when i say tense he's the only
top part of the movie that at times i felt some
tension sure otherwise i was just amused i was
consistently amused twice a little sleepy like
most part consistently amused i know it sounds
like a weird discussion i was gonna say you know
fun enough you know you got sleepy twice that's
a solid three out of five it was all right better
than i expected i would watch a second movie with
better versions of everything we saw here i love
the poster quote i kind of liked it only sleeping
twice correct albert real paychecks like that
it's the feeling i had it's a fun vampire movie
i guess i feel like the vampire movie comes
from matt smith i think everything else is
kind of like it's more of a science movie science
experiment movie i grew up in vampire movies i got
a lot of the love of vampire movies on screen i
also liked the cast a lot and i love their dynamic
all of them personally but again like i grew up
with this character from the time i could read
i really loved morbius and i never
thought we'd see him so i cannot shake
that i cannot remove my bias of loving this
character and i also can't remove my bias of
an academy award-winning actor actually caring
enough to invest in this character so there's
no version of me that can't be like
man i got to be a kid and i wanted that
i got it and it's a vampire movie that we don't
get the style of a lot had a good time personally
yeah man no one's trying to take you down
they're not that's not the way i feel like
you're defending i'm defending myself for the
comments that are coming you know what those
comments are going to say coy likes everything
why do you have them on the real rejects he's just
going to say it's good and they don't know what i
think about a lot of things first thoughts toy's
very enthusiastic and john and i are like sure
it's good enough try it out for me i think it's
venom morbius then let there be carnage that's
how i would rank it i agree more obvious is
the top three and then you know venom and venom
two is all three out of five three out of five
did you like it more than the venom movies
no i liked them in the same order you did
we're all venomous yeah yeah all right
guys well koi thanks for hopping in here
i'll go back to work gotta get my stuff and g
fuel your energy drink kept us awake for this
review maybe if we didn't have g fuel we would
have been more bored so this movie kept us away